[Music]  it is 6 24 here on a monday morning  easter sunday marked 53 years since the  assassination of civil rights leader dr  martin luther king jr  he was shot and killed at the lorraine  motel in memphis tennessee  dr king is among many things as a civil  rights leader he was a pastor at  ebenezer baptist church in atlanta  now at that same church on sunday pastor  and now senator raphael warnock talked  about dr king's legacy  although he transitioned on this day 53  years ago  he had the courage to face death  because he understood as we do that  death does not have the last word  sickness does not have the last word  oppression does not have the last word  racism and bigotry  will never have the last word  james earl ray pleaded guilty to dr  king's murder in 1969 he later recanted  his confession